today the Matt wall show As Americans
head to the polls today the media is
already warning that the ballots could
take weeks to count not just days but
weeks there's no way to avoid this they
say well then how did we avoid it every
election until two years ago also some
Democrats are starting to realize when
it's already too late that focusing
their campaign on abortion was not the
best idea meanwhile others on the left
have doubled down and made abortion in
their closing pitch and I had a long and
interesting conversation with Joe Rogan
yesterday I'll share my thoughts on that
finally 60 Minutes airs a report about
the danger that Tick Tock poses to our
children but they actually understate
the case considerably I think we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what are your family's values Faith
Church on Sunday did you vaccinate your
kids did you choose not to vaccinate
your kids how does your family Define
men and women your children look to you
to Define their values and their
perspectives of the world but in the
event that you die who will ensure that
the values you hold dear are upheld by
your kids epic will can help with that
it will let you determine who will raise
your kids in the event that you die
before you're done raising them this is
a big deal and it's your responsibility
as a parent it's why we at the daily
wire have partnered with epic will take
five minutes a day go to epicwell.com
use promo code Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package more
importantly uh you got to do this so
that I know that you did it so that
you're accountable to me so that I know
that you took this crucial step towards
doing the right thing and taking care of
your family I know who you are I will be
checking on you go to epicworld.com
promo code Welsh
before we get started here today I need
to mention something that I announced on
Joe Rogan's show yesterday I'll have
more to say about the interview with Joe
Rogan and the great conversation we had
later on in the show for now we'll let
you know that the first 15 minutes of my
film what is a woman are now available
to watch for free and for non-members at
whatisawoman.com if you haven't seen the
film yet haven't yet been convinced that
it's uh worth getting the membership for
head over to what iswoman.com for an
extended preview and as I said we'll
talk more about the interview with Joe
Rogan a little bit later on uh now as
voters head to the polls today Democrats
you know those Fierce Defenders of the
democratic process have already sent the
word out don't trust the results
at least don't trust them at first to be
more specific the Democrat Party message
about voting results is that you
shouldn't trust them until they the
Democrats start winning
ABC News makes the case in typical
fashion warning of a red Mirage not a
red wave but a red Mirage
they say as early Election Day Results
come in on Tuesday will likely appear
appear that Republican candidates vying
for any number of the federal or
Statewide races appear to be leading
their Democratic opponents even by large
margins their leads will dwindle or
crumble completely after perceived dumps
of votes are recorded by state election
officials who count mail-in and absentee
ballots in the days or even weeks
following election day this phenomenon
was popularized as the red Mirage or the
blue shift after the 2020 presidential
election when former president Donald
Trump took a deceptive lead in several
competitive States on Election Day due
to delays and Counting of Democrats
mail-in ballots their preferred method
of voting due to the kova 19 pandemic
only to eventually dissipate when the
entire reserve of votes was totaled
um now
that's what they say but
if kovid was allegedly to blame for the
alleged red Mirage then why are they
warning that it will happen again I mean
the pandemic is over remember Joe Biden
said so himself
ABC continues this is likely to occur
again on Tuesday according to election
experts because of the same cocktail of
factors that led to a red Mirage in
2020. Democrats have continued to use
mail-in voting more than their
Republican counterparts while some of
the same decisive States will take a
longer time to tally their mail-in
absentee and provisional ballots due to
state laws that prohibit their account
until late stages in the electoral
process and it's likely to occur in some
of the same states where the phenomenon
presented itself last cycle in States
like Pennsylvania Michigan and Wisconsin
Battleground states that also happen to
feature some of the most hotly contested
races of the election season
so the real cocktail of factors is that
these states choose to count their
ballots this way even though they don't
have to in fact the article acknowledges
that after the chaos of the 2020
election there were bipartisan calls for
States like Pennsylvania Wisconsin to
change their laws to make it easier to
count the ballots on Election Day
they chose not to make the change
so it doesn't have to be this way
it never was this way until just two
years ago
but now that it is this way Democrats
say it must be this way and it should be
this way I mean this is the leftist
specialty right radically changing
something and then insisting that the
thing now changed could never be
anything other than what it is now even
though it was something else entirely
five seconds ago
that was basically Karen Jean pair's
message yesterday from the White House
here she is
it took two weeks to call every state in
modern elections more and more ballots
are being cast in early voting and also
by mail and many states don't start
counting those ballots until after the
ballots uh after pardon me after the
polls close on November 8th so you heard
the president say this the other night
he has been very clear on this as well
we may not know all but winners of
Elections for a few days it takes time
to count all legitimate ballots in a
legal and orderly manner that's how
that's how this is supposed to work and
it's important for us to all be patient
when while votes are are being counted
that's how this is supposed to work
there is of course it's supposed to take
weeks is what you just said
now there's of course no reason at all
why it should take days much less weeks
to count ballots
she says that these are modern elections
well in any other context the mark of
modernity is that things are done
quicker and more efficiently
why should it take longer to count
ballots in 2022 than it took in like
1802.
they say the reason is that so many
people have voted early and by mail well
that explanation doesn't really make
sense because if you have the ballots
early shouldn't it be if anything easier
to get them counted on Election Day
if it isn't if early voting really makes
it somehow impossible to declare a
winner on the same day or even the same
week
then that's all the more reason to
abolish early voting
putting aside active duty military
perhaps a few other isolated exceptions
the drawbacks of early voting and mass
mail-in voting are substantially greater
than the advantages obviously
that's a rather easy judgment call to
make because there really aren't any
advantages significant enough to be
factored in or weighed
the current system you know with mail
and voting and early voting it affords
people the opportunity to vote in their
pajamas with as little effort as
possible and without leaving their homes
okay
that doesn't solve any problem or meet
any pressing need
there's nothing wrong with requiring
minimal effort from the electorate in
fact it's a positive good to acquire
minimal effort
and besides even with same-day in-person
voting you can still vote in your
pajamas it's not like people care about
dressing presentably in public these
days anyway so the advantage is that it
makes it makes even easier something
which was already extremely easy
arguably too easy
what are the drawbacks
well with early voting for one thing
you're voting before the campaign is
over
the candidates haven't finished making
their cases you may not know everything
you need to know about them what if a
candidate just to pull an example at
random
say has a stroke and becomes brain
damaged after you've already voted for
him now in fetterman's case the brain
damage happened before the primaries had
even finished but it still demonstrates
the sorts of surprises and changes that
can present themselves during a campaign
all the more reason to vote at the end
of The Campaign not in the middle of it
I mean there are a lot of people who
after that debate with fetterman and Oz
a couple weeks ago decided to uh that
they didn't want to vote for fetterman
anymore well some of those people had
already voted for him
for another thing early voting does in
fact provide more opportunities for
cheating whatever you think about the
prevalence of cheating there is no
debate that the longer you take
to count the ballots the more
complicated and confusing it is the more
chances for funny business to occur and
and that's obviously going to be the
case
and finally the current system to use a
phrase that we so often hear from
Democrats these days
um destabilizes our democracy
and there seems to be no disagreement on
this point right the media the White
House the Democrat Party they all
acknowledge that when States take days
or weeks to announce a winner in highly
contentious and pivotal races it creates
lots of public anxiety and concern about
the integrity and reliability of the
results
they openly admit this they're
predicting it
they tell us ahead of time that
Pennsylvania will take forever to count
its ballots because it shows not to fix
its balancing system and that this will
create from the perspective of a wide
swath of the population
the appearance of impropriety
well here's the point
even if you don't think that cheating is
happening or that it will happen even
though it certainly does and will in
every election
the fact that doing it
this way causes many people to have less
less faith in the results that's reason
enough to not do it this way
the Citizens need to trust the results
if they don't the whole system breaks
down
that is the house of cards that the
entire system is based on the trust of
the electric if you don't have that you
don't have anything
do the Democrats not see or not
understand these immense drawbacks to
mass early voting and mail and vote no
of course they see it and they
understand it but to them
these are not drawbacks they are the
point they are features not bugs
we can only conclude that they want
people to vote early and vote by mail
because it means they're locking in
their choice before the campaign is over
and because it gives the opportunity for
let's say post-election adjustments
quote unquote and because it
destabilizes our democracy
the the one thing they claim to fear the
most is exactly what they in fact want
and are attempting to engineer
because the left seeks always to
destabilize destroy demoralize
preservation even of democracy is never
their goal
and that's all the more reason why they
need to pay the political price
they need to be thrown out of office
and we have to do it with the system
that is currently in place however
horrifically flawed it may be
take over the system and fix it that has
to be the goal
but it starts with your vote
now let's get to the five headlines
you know going online without expressvpn
it's like changing uh like changing your
clothes with the window open you might
not you might not be seen maybe not but
why would you give anyone the chance to
invade your privacy when you go online
without a VPN internet service providers
can see every single website you visit
what's more they can legally sell that
information to ad companies and Tech
Giants without your consent that's why I
use expressvpn expressvpn hides my
online activity from internet service
providers my identity is um is made
Anonymous and my data is encrypted for
maximum protection if it sounds
complicated it really isn't all I have
to do is fire up the app and click one
button and uh that's it I'm free to roam
the internet without any prying eyes
expressvpn works on all devices
including phones laptops routers so that
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected secure your online activity
today by visiting expressvpn.com Walsh
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-ssvpn.com Walsh to get an
extra three months free of expressvpn
again that's Express
vpn.com Welsh
here's a headline to start with the
Baltimore Sun which is the biggest
newspaper in Maryland
they tweeted this yesterday and this is
100 real I promise you this is not a
Photoshop is the Baltimore Sun they they
tweeted
you fell off Matt Walsh no one likes you
LOL
as a real tweet from this uh from this
newspaper
fact check true
single tier rolls down the face actually
never mind come to think of it fact
check false missing context because if
no one likes me it doesn't mean I fell
off
because no one ever liked me to begin
with
so gotcha checkmate mic drop
you may have already guessed that the
sun's Twitter was hacked and uh that's
how this tweet ended up getting briefly
posted
but not before I was able to screenshot
that tweet and make it my header image
on Twitter so I'm very happy about that
all right um we'll move to this it's a
little bit late in the game for this
realization but here's Chris saliza on
cnn.com
headline did Democrats place a losing
bet on abortion
he goes on in the immediate aftermath of
the Supreme Court decision overturning
Roe v Wade Democratic strategist
insisted the 2022 midterms had
fundamentally shifted rather than an
election about the economy focused on
Rising gas prices and inflation they
argued the election would now be a
referendum on abortion rights and the
Republicans working to limit women's
choices
Democrats put their money where their
mouth was in the month of October alone
listen to this Democratic campaigns and
groups spent 214 million dollars on
broadcast TV ads that mentioned abortion
214 million according to a CNN analysis
of the data they accounted for nearly
half of all the ad money spent by the
party over that time and it dwarfed ad
spending on other topics the next
biggest issue for Democrats was crime
with the party spending 79 million on
the issue less than 17 percent of its
overall ad expenditures last month
um how much do they spend on ads
mentioning the economy it says uh the
Democrats spent less than 68 million
dollars on ads mentioning Taxation and
less than 18 million dollars on ads
about inflation in October
okay look at that contrast
214 million dollars
about abortion
and they spent
almost 200 million dollars Less on the
number one economic issue that people
are actually worried about
by contrast Republicans spent nearly 144
million dollars on ads referencing
taxation over the same period and nearly
77 million on ads mentioning
um mentioning inflation
and the problem for the Democrats now is
that they're looking at the polls and
what they find is that um
the vast majority of of people who
answer polls even even a CNN poll
uh the vast majority of people are not
choosing abortion as their top issue
in a CNN poll 29 of democratic voters
named abortion as their top issue
that's that's less than 30 percent of
democrat voters see abortion as their
top issue
what does that tell you
I mean I I love to say I told you so and
I said from the beginning
when Roe v Wade was overturned and we
started hearing all these predictions
about how this was going to radically
change you know the the the game and in
the coming midterms that this was all
gonna be about abortion now it's gonna
be a referendum on abortion people are
going to flock to the polls to protect
their so-called abortion rights
I said from the beginning that you know
that's not going to happen it's just not
going to happen
because most people don't care about
abortion that much
as I always say they should care about
it they should care about it in the
sense of being pro-life and wanting to
protect
unborn babies
but you know passivity indifference
on the abortion issue this has been one
of the main hurdles one of the main
obstacles that pro-lifers have been
dealing with for like 40 years
and now for the first time the Democrats
are running into it as well
but then it also makes sense that I mean
even if you're pro-life as I am
protecting unborn babies is one of my
top issues one of the most important
things to me
but also if you if you have your own
kids
um the things that the the the the
things that are going to be like
plaguing your mind every SEC of the day
things you think about when you first
wake up there could be things that
affect your your kids that you have
things like the economy their safety
these sorts of things
and the Democrats ignored that issue
essentially and they're going to pay the
price for it
don't tell that to Jimmy Kimmel though
who brought his wife on during his
monologue yesterday to Galvanize Pro and
fantasized voters so he's making his
final pitch before people go to the
polls brought his wife out for it
another another moment of brilliant
comedy here from Jimmy Kimmel let's
let's watch it
oh
is uh this is um
my wife Molly what are you doing
[Applause]
I didn't know we had an arm oh we do I I
didn't either it was backstage okay um
why are you uh sounding an alarm you
found backstage because tomorrow is
election day and abortion rights are
gone or in danger in 26 States even
though the overwhelming majority of this
country supports a woman's right to
choose
every time you have sex is your
intention to have a baby no I just wait
till you eat a gummy and then try to
snuggle in
[Applause]
the hardest okay pause it there for a
second I can't just just a note here
um
every time you have sex is your
intention have a baby well obviously not
and you can't conceive a child every
time you have sex
there's just like basic realities of the
biology of a woman and menstrual cycles
and so on that you would you would hope
Jimmy Kimmel's wife would understand
that would mean that that's not on the
table every time you have sex
you're not going to conceive a child
every time
okay you're not gonna if you have if you
have uh sex 10 times in a month you're
gonna conceived 10 children it's not the
way it works
it's a really good chance you won't even
conceive one
now so is it your intention every time
you have sex to have a baby well
obviously not again if you understand
basic human biology and how these things
work then then you're gonna know that
that's not always going to happen
um however
are you as an adult aware
that that sex is the reproductive act
that this is how babies are made babies
are not made every time
they're not made most of the times when
you have sex but it is it is how they
are made and so there is that potential
even if you're using birth control
they're still technically the potential
so that's that's what matters are you
aware of that
and
being aware that the potential is there
did you engage in the ACT anyway
if you did
you chose to have sex you're aware that
it's the reproductive act which means
that there's the potential for babies to
be created
and you had sex anyway that means that
when the baby if if a baby is created
you chose that you already made your
choice you've already made your choice
and the baby already exists
and now if you're a woman you're already
a mother and if you're if you're a man
you're already a father it's already
happened
the reproductive Choice was made you
made that when you had sex not because
again every time you have sex you're
trying to create a baby but because
you're an adult hopefully you understand
basic human biology and you know that
every time you have sex there is that
potential
and you chose to do it so you made your
reproductive when it comes to
reproductive Choice reproductive choice
is made
um in the let's say marital bed that's
where the reproductive choice is made if
you're married which hopefully you are
that's what the choices mean
once the baby exists reproduction has
already occurred so it's too late to
make a choice about whether or not
you're going to reproduce
just a little bit of fact check there
but let's uh let's keep watching a
little bit
imagine her will
and the women
six out of ten women who have an
abortion already have kids at home they
know how hard the job is 92 percent of
abortions happen in the first 13 weeks a
good portion of the women who need one
after the first trimester do it because
of Health complications that could kill
her or her baby
roughly half the women who have
abortions live below the poverty line
I'm sorry are you expecting this to be
funny because it is not going to be
funny no we weren't expecting that they
don't have the resources to raise the
Jimmy Kimmel show we were not we don't
have the money to drive to another state
to get health care
the only person who should be making a
life-altering and potentially
life-saving decision for a woman and her
body is the woman herself
I'm not out here with this dumb alarm
asking you guys to love abortion I'm
asking you to love women enough to trust
women enough to make their own difficult
decisions and to vote for the people who
will make that happen tomorrow our
daughters should not have to fight the
battles that our grandmothers won
great uh and this is what they're
they're hoping we'll Galvanize again the
pro and fantaside masses to get out
there and uh and it will I mean there
will be some who show up but the thing
is the people that care that deeply
about abortion
like this is the most important thing in
the world to them these are like
left-wing activists who are already
going to be voting
uh who are already going to vote three
or four times probably and even their
dead relatives are already going to vote
so they've already enlisted everyone
they can you've already got them
but if you're trying to speak to the
heart and soul of just like the average
American the average American we talk
about what they wake up worrying about
they don't wake up worried that their
children won't be able to kill their
grandchildren when they get older that's
just not what they're worried about
and I always have to ask whenever this
comes up and you always hear this in
these up in these pro-abortion speeches
a woman should be able to make this
difficult choice for herself
but what makes it a difficult choice
why is the choice difficult
is it if it's just a clump of cells
doesn't mean anything it's a
reproductive decision
it's not difficult at all what makes it
difficult the only thing that makes it
difficult is if we are acknowledging and
recognizing the humanity of the baby
if we're doing that then we see that
this has nothing to do with the woman's
choice
that's not the question here the
question is not whether women have a
choice
they did have a choice just like the man
had a choice before he engaged in the
reproductive Act
that's not the question the question is
whether a human child
possesses basic human rights or if those
human rights are magically
uh
you know imbued into the child when he
passes through the birth canal that's
the question
and of course we know that the latter
just doesn't make any sense at all
all right as mentioned I was on Joe
Rogan yesterday actually I was on his
show last week but the episode aired
yesterday and it was a it was great to
appear on the show it was on or it was
surreal surreal too because I I think I
you know I started listening to Joe
Rogan's podcast
uh I don't know eight eight or nine
years ago maybe
and it was a I thought really good
conversation the first half of which
about 90 minutes was dedicated to uh the
film what is a woman and issues
surrounding it lots of Clips are
circulating from that part of the
conversation or you could watch the
whole episode which is what I'd
recommend on Spotify
but I wanted to play this one moment in
particular was interesting uh in my in
my biased opinion in my humble opinion I
thought this was an interesting moment
when we talked about the ways that
narcissism drives gender ideology and
this is a point that Joe Rogan brought
up and made and then I you know said my
piece and here's that
you're giving them an opportunity to be
special and to get special treatment
without any special act they haven't
done anything that warrants that
unique Behavior yeah I think it's a
really important point I think I think
that's that's actually so much of this
that and and people don't notice it but
a lot of this is uh is just it's just
standard narcissism yes especially
listen to these you know why is this so
common among celebrities now all the
celebrities have have trans kids and
they're coming out as non-binary and
whatever else and then you listen to
like Demi Lovato whoever and you listen
to them explain why they're they them
it's always well I just uh I I just I
don't identify with these labels I'm
beyond that I'm above that it's like
these labels were good enough for
billions of humans before you but it's
not good enough for you that you can't
find yourself there but but all these
other billions of human beings it was
fine they had no problem but you're so
special that we need to change the rules
of the English language for you
specifically it's it's incredibly
egotistical it's bizarre it's like if
you feel that you're different than
everyone else
you're still a female you're just a
different human being who happens to be
a female if you're so unique go prove it
with your actions prove it with your
work prove it out there in the world but
to demand this very special attention
and that's what we give people like if
you give people that thing today they'll
tell that there's groups of people that
will tell you you're amazing you're
incredible you're beautiful you're brave
it gives them positive affirmation for
making these decisions
it's also it's also a part of what
you're describing is personality right I
mean it so if you're saying I'm a I'm a
female but I don't identify with girly
things and I don't like the color pink
and whatever
okay that's your personality and it's
fine there are many ways to be a woman
there are many ways to be a man there's
like almost infinite ways of doing it
because each man and woman has their own
personality their own perspective of the
world and that's fine so I think that
what I'm expressing is more the kind of
traditional ideas much more uh expansive
because it allows you as a man to just
you know be be who you are you're still
a man but be who you are the idea now is
that if you're well if you're a man but
you
um you have interests or ideas that fall
outside of the standard Norm now you
lose your manhood you're actually a
woman so they're actually reinforcing
the gender binary while trying to
destroy it at the same time which is
interesting but I think most of what
they're
trying to describe is actually just
personality and now we have this
situation where you know you could have
a person who has five different genders
and six sexual orientations but no
personality because their personality
has been
subsumed by all of these labels they've
categorized and labeled and everything
and and it's uh it's really strange
this is really good to hear uh I'm not
talking about my part that was really
good to hear from me now it's good it's
I can't emphasize enough how great it is
to hear from somebody like Joe Rogan
with his audience
now I could go out there and make the
case and talk about these things and I
will and I do and I hope that I can have
some effect but uh it you know Joe Rogan
who the left is trying to try to sort of
brand him as this right-wing extremist
fundamentalist which of course it
couldn't be further from the truth as
we'll fight as we'll see in the next
clip we're going to play but um
that's obviously not what he who he is
and what he is and he has a you know me
he's just he's like a mainstream guy in
a lot of ways and he has a mainstream
audience
and here he is identifying the truth
which is that gender ideology is rooted
in narcissism it's rooted in
self-obsession
um and a lot of it
is is you know born from this
desire that people have to you know not
be like everybody else
to just be kind of a normal person seems
boring and it's uh beneath them and so
it's their vanity that says that no that
you know I because
you only have access to your own inner
experience
obviously you don't have access to
anybody else's
and so if you have your inner experience
and you just assume so if you're a man
having an inner experience
like how could you even say that well
this is not the inner experience that a
man is supposed to have how do you know
that
you you only have you're a man and this
is your inner experience and so and
you've only ever experienced the inner
experience of one man which is yourself
so how do you know what are you
comparing it to
I think a lot of it there's mental
illness wrapped up in this as well there
are other factors but in many cases
especially with the older people
especially with celebrities as we said
it's just the Assumption it's the
vanity-based assumption that whatever
they're feeling must be more profound
much must be very different from what
other people experience and so they
can't make do with the labels that
billions of people before them have made
do with
now the second half of the interview
became a debate about gay marriage and I
wasn't expecting really that we would
talk about that issue but it came up and
that's how things developed and I was
happy to talk about it
um it is of course a you know it's a
it's a
relatively high pressure situation in
front of a very large audience debating
a guy who on this issue anyway is
diametrically opposed to my view
and uh I think going into a situation
like this it's important first of all to
you know you don't want to get defensive
or combative there are occasions where
being combative and taking that stance
is appropriate and as you know I'm more
than happy to
to you know approach something that way
if it calls for it but talking to a guy
like Joe Rogan an environment like that
it's going to hurt your cause more than
help it if you seem to be getting sort
of like defensive and angry so you don't
want to you don't want to take that
approach you also don't want to get lost
in the weeds and I know I'm always
harping on this but this is a mistake I
see people make all the time getting
lost in the weeds debating 100 different
side topics tangentially connected to
the main one and that's what can so how
so often happen on a topic like this if
you talk about it especially for as long
as we did we went on about it for like
an hour
and then of course the final mistake the
conservatives can often make when it
comes to this issue in particular which
is marriage uh the the mistake that they
can make was just to fold and run away
and not want to talk about it at all and
or even to suddenly adopt the opposite
view in order to get along and seem cool
in front of the new audience so
obviously I wasn't going to do that
um the goal then is to try to calmly lay
out a defensive marriage in a clear and
simple and firm way
that's what I attempted to do anyway
we'll play this club it's kind of long
it's about three minutes uh as I said
this is from an I don't know an 80
minute
back and forth on this topic that was
that took up basically the second half
of the podcast
and you can go and watch the whole thing
if you want but I think this gives us a
pretty good uh Taste of of what it was
let's watch it
what if any negative aspects would there
be to people doing that if they're gay
well the issue is that
from my perspective and from their
perspective of most human societies that
have existed
in history
is that marriage is
the the context in which the the
procreative union occurs marriage is the
foundation for the family
um it is uh it's something that is
reserved for that because the male
female Union has this capacity to create
life
whereas no other Union has that capacity
and so it's it's it is a different kind
of thing and it makes sense to call it
something different it's like if you
know if if Human Society were to
collapse overnight and we all woke up
with an Amnesia and didn't remember
anything about what happened before and
and we're rebuilding Society from
scratch and we look around and we see
that oh there are some couplings over
here that have this weird habit of
creating people and there are other
couplings where there are no people
being created
we would probably call that something
different it's a different kind of thing
it's also more important to society like
Society needs that you're you're going
to keep Society going because you're
creating people
um and that's what marriage was it was
the it was the context
for that procreative Union but what
about gay couples who get surrogate
parents to carry their children or who
adopt children that's very common
yeah it's it's common but that's not the
union itself is not creating
but it's a man-made institution we've
decided that we should involve the law
and to join a male and a female who
create a family like why would that be
mutually exclusive why would that why
would that not apply to a gay couple
well again part of it is it's a it's a
matter of definitions so it's a little
bit like the what is a woman question
it's like what is What is marriage I
mean I I
but doesn't that seem like an easier one
like two people who love each other this
is my life partner this is the person I
want to be with so the way I die Let's
Get Married everybody is Happy everybody
celebrates what just two people why just
two people
why why only two people with
heterosexuals because that's not it was
on the case well because only two people
can create another person you know
um no you could have another person
involved and they can have your kid too
I mean is that what the Mormons did yeah
but only but only two people can
actually create
two people at a time right right exactly
okay
um and yeah that's one of the reasons
why I would also you know if we want to
call it heterosexual uh polygamy I'm not
a proponent of that because
you know when when two people create
another person the person the child that
they've created
now needs and deserves and has a right
to
um be raised in a stable environment
with a with a mom and a dad who are
living together in the house that's what
we should Endeavor as a society to
provide every uh child and children need
they need both a child needs a mom and a
dad
you know one thing that kept coming up
over the course of the of the following
hour was the question of what harm
is caused by gay marriage you know he
Revisited this this point uh asked the
question several different times
how does it harm anyone to expand the
definition of marriage
and again on that point you could go
many different directions potentially
and there there are a lot of weeds you
could get lost in but from my experience
talking about issues like this in
hostile environments not that Joe Rogan
was hostile to me personally I just mean
in in in you know in an environment
where people are opposed to what you're
saying
and in that kind of environment you want
to focus on the strongest points and
again not not get lost
which I see people do all the time and
so I tried to convey that the primary
harm caused by expanding marriage
is to make it meaningless to make it
irrelevant
um and thus to make the institution
itself Irrelevant in people's eyes
which as I pointed out later on in the
conversation where we are seeing that
play out right now
you know we're seeing people giving up
on marriage marriage rates are declining
the the age of first marriage is going
up because the few or few people are
getting married or it's not a priority
to them and so they're waiting uh longer
to get married
and because they they see it as uh as
you know not an important thing it's
basically irrelevant
in a funny way Joe Rogan actually agreed
with me in in a certain way because he
he said at one point that he thinks
marriage is uh
is in his word silly
and that was my point by by discarding
the procreative aspect of marriage it's
fundamental purpose it's defining
features or one of its most important
defining features you make it useless
and pointless you make it yeah silly
you know I he defined it there marriage
is between two people who love each
other
you know I asked them well well why two
people
no real reason for it to be just two
people and uh and why I mean how do you
define love and why do they need to love
each other and why do you need a piece
of paperwork
codifying the fact that you love someone
what's the point of that it just see it
it does seem that seems silly so that
version of marriage this as we want to
call expanded definition which you can't
really expand the definition you could
just destroy the definition you can
dismantle it but with that dismantle
definition you end up with something
that is silly
um and of course the reality for both of
us is that once you wade into these
Waters
on a topic like this it is in some ways
it's like a it's a lose-lose proposition
for Joe Rogan it is because even though
he's disagreeing with me
uh the very fact that he has me on the
show and that he's talking about this
and that he's letting me make my case
and he's taking my argument seriously
that's going to get him in trouble on
the left and it did and for me on a
topic like this in that environment um
obviously the left's gonna hate me for
what I say but who cares about that
but also on the right there's going to
be a lot of Monday morning
quarterbacking no matter no matter how
you approach it like whatever argument
you make there's gonna be people say
well you should have made this argument
instead whatever approach you take well
you should have taken that approach
and uh and that's fine most most mostly
from people who have never
debated any of these issues in an
environment any more high stakes than
their living room or their Twitter page
and yet they are pretty sure they know
how they would have handled it fine
whatever
um
but I did want to address one thing
uh one criticism that I've heard from
people on the right for how I approach
this
and what I've heard from so from some
Christians is that I should have based
my argument on scripture on God now I
shouldn't have as I'm accused taken God
out of it which I didn't of course
anytime you're talking about the true
definition of marriage you can't you
can't you can't take God out of that God
is there
um but I should have explicitly said
that marriage is a man and a woman
because that's how God designed it and
that's what scripture declares that's
what they wanted me to say and I didn't
say that
but here's the problem
uh
to me it's quite obvious
to a secular audience arguing that
marriage is a certain way because the
Bible says so is not going to be
convincing or useful to them that's not
gonna be a a useful argument in that
environment
because in order for the Bible says so
to be a compelling argument
uh you first need the other person in
the discussion to believe that there is
a God and that the Bible is his word so
those are two big things you need that
person to accept before because the
Bible says so is going to mean anything
to them
and I don't really see the point of
having an argument with someone or
trying to communicate with them if you
are not going to say things that are
meaningful to them
which means that if you want if you know
if you want to take it that direction
then that would mean that you need to
actually abandon the marriage
conversation completely and instead say
you know what let's first debate about
the existence of God and and the
validity of the Bible
and then you you just you've you've
abandoned the marriage conversation
entirely so you can have this other
debate
and I think that would be a very
unfortunate decision and I do see
Christians do this sometimes on on topic
like marriage
when they're asked well you know why do
you believe in so-called traditional
marriage and very often I'll hear a
Christian say well because Bible because
God says so Bible says so
and then it becomes a debate about the
existence of God
and I find that
an unfortunate strategy
because there is a defense of the nature
of marriage that you can make
without immediately throwing the Bible
verse at the person who doesn't care
what the Bible says
and the defense is exactly what I tried
to articulate there that marriage is a
certain thing it has a certain
definition which is based in its in in
the actual physical function of the
man-woman relationship
and that's also as we as we talked about
later on in the conversation that's also
why you find uh through history marriage
as an institution exists in every
culture in history
even cultures that are not Christian
now there might be some cultures where
they have polygamy or things like that
but the idea of marriage existing and to
be being between a man and a woman and
being a fundamentally procreative act
you find that all throughout history and
all over the world
because it's a matter of just natural
law it's it's you could find it in in
nature
and it's uh it's a in a lot of ways a
common sense thing
the man-woman relationship has this
capacity to create people and uh that
sets this relationship apart from any
other kind of relationship and it also
makes it important to society in ways
that other relationships simply aren't
it needs to be protected in ways that
other relationships simply don't because
of its capacity to create people and
because it is whether you like it or not
going to be the foundation of the family
and thereby the foundation of human
civilization
and you know the good thing is that if
if you can make that argument and of
course you're not going to convince
someone in the moment on something like
this most likely you're not going to
but you make the argument you make the
point
uh if you can
even get someone to take it seriously
and listen to you
you know you've brought them closer to
the truth
which means that you've also brought
them closer to God because God is truth
so that was the approach that which to
me seems clearly
uh the way to go in that kind of
environment all right we're going to not
have five whole headlines because uh we
got to get now to the comment section
[Music]
well if you're a small business owner
you know how important it is to be
prepared for the holiday season if you
haven't started preparing for the chaos
of holiday mailing and shipping you're
already behind but luckily stamps.com is
everything you need to make your life
much easier you can sign up now and
you'll be printing your own postage in
minutes stamps.com is a One-Stop shop
for all your shipping and mailing needs
it's a 24 7 post office that you can
access from anywhere no lines no traffic
no hassle for 20 years stamps.com has
been indispensable for over one million
businesses you get access to the USPS
and UPS services that you need to run
your business right from your computer
uh even save up to 86 percent on USPS
and UPS shipping rates use stamps.com to
print postage wherever you do business
all you need is a computer and a printer
it's as simple as that if you need a
package picked up you can easily
schedule it through your stamps.com
dashboard everything is very easy that's
the name of the game rates are
constantly changing with stamps.com
switch and save feature you can easily
compare carriers and rates so you know
you're getting the the best deal every
time if you're running an online store
stamps.com Works seamlessly with all the
major shipping shopping carts and
marketplaces so get ahead of the holiday
chaos this year get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
Walsh for a special offer that includes
a four week trial plus free postage and
a free digital skill no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code Walsh
all right I'll jump you out of two
headlines there I'll have to make it up
to you later uh Bradley Tarr says when
are we going to stop blaming politicians
and representatives and Mayors for crime
and start blaming fatherless homes
well I think we can you know who says we
have to choose we can blame them all but
yeah fatherless homes are at the root of
all this
uh which is why again marriage serves as
the foundation of human civilization you
get away from Marriage
and then you end up with uh you're
getting away from civilization
civilization starts to collapse as we're
as we're seeing especially in a lot of
these communities uh so you're right
um
but that doesn't mean that we let
politicians and uh and Mayors and off
the hook especially because if they're
Democrats
they are
uh behind this agenda to undermine the
family and marriage and to destroy it
which means that they are creating more
fatherless homes
uh
j-rod says I'll be honest the opening
guitar riff for the show is tasty AF
I don't even know what that means j-rod
but thanks I guess
um Abdi says I'm so disappointed with my
grandpa he's voting Democrat next week
when he was alive he was a staunch
Republican
well done
well done sir uh or ma'am
let's see Aaron blank says even if the
thing about inflation not being in the
common lexicon were true is Joy Reed
suggesting that learning new English
vocabulary terms is a bad thing
uh right that's the other that was the
other interesting thing about her claim
that well no one used the word inflation
before
that's obviously not correct but also
well well then great then they learned a
new term they learned a useful new
economic term
and obviously it doesn't matter if they
use the term or not everybody
understands the idea that like prices
are going up so whether you call that
inflation whatever you call it it's
something that we can all see happening
and we're all experiencing
uh broken controller says hey Matt I was
just curious if when JK Rowling tweeted
out her stance on trans people and
Daniel Radcliffe revolted
would you have had the same reaction if
she had tweeted defending abortion and
Daniel Radcliffe had revolted against
her then I know an unlikely scenario
if you'd have the same reaction then
great but if not wouldn't that suggest
your problem with Radcliffe is more with
the stance that he took and less that he
took it against the woman who gave him
his career I just can't imagine you
attacking someone for holding a position
that agrees with yours because it
disagrees with someone else any response
would be appreciated SPG for life well
you are right I um
I mean guilty as charged so the fact
that Daniel Radcliffe came after JK
Rowling for her stance defending
biological reality
uh I I criticized him for the disloyalty
that this woman as you say gave him
his career and then he turns around
stabs her in the back but I'm
I'm all the more critical because the
position that he's taking is wrong
and so I'm always going to give a lot
more leeway to people when they're right
if he was throwing her onto the bus in
the name of truth then that would
certainly paint his his actions in a at
least a more favorable light
so it's always worse to defend alive
than to defend the truth
but even then you know part of it is is
it's not just that he's wrong
it's that he's jumping on a dog pile
right
like whether JK Rowling is wrong or
right and obviously she's right about
this issue
but they're already
50 million other people telling her that
she's wrong and criticizing her
and she's she's so she's already got
this massive dog pile on top of her uh
trying to rip her to shreds and so so
what what even is is like even if she
actually was wrong right so let's say
she says something and she's and she's
wrong about what she says and then
you've got millions of people dog piling
on her and then you're someone you know
her and she's been she's been someone
who's been very important to your career
you're gonna jump on the dog pile
what's what's even even if you don't
know or what's the point
like she's already this this there's
already 50 million people who came
before you to make the same so what do
you need to get your hidden for
why do you need to just come along and
like kick this person when they're
already on the ground
uh but then to do it to write to do it
to someone who's been so important to
your career it just shows a disloyalty
uh and and the appropriate way to to
handle that situation like if you know
someone if you're professionally tied to
someone
again it doesn't mean that you never
criticize them publicly uh it does mean
that you should be
very hesitant to jump on a dog pile
again whether they're wrong or right
but if you do feel the need
to criticize them it should start
personally like privately you reach out
to them privately and you and you and
you you let them know your thoughts
because you because you know them right
um rather than as they did to her just
as I said jumping on the Dogpile like
that
well today is going to be a bloodbath at
least we're hoping and I for one could
not be more excited and I'm inviting you
to tune in and watch our special daily
wire election night 2022 coverage
election coverage starts at 3 P.M
Central and then starting at 6 p.m uh
Ben Shapiro Michael Knowles Andrew
Clavin our god king with lowercase G
Jeremy boring Candace Owens and myself
we'll be giving our live updates as the
results come in with help of our morning
wire crew we'll also be mocking social
media meltdowns that will surely be
happening for the likes of AOC and many
others we hope and there will also be
some very special guests joining us for
commentary as well the daily wire
election night 2022 will uh be giving
will be the gift that keeps on giving
this year and you don't want to miss a
second of it if you're not yet a member
go to dailywire.com Walsh and join us
today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we turn
to 60 minutes but not to cancel them
this time in fact 60 Minutes on Sunday
committed a rare and we must suspect
inadvertent Act of Journalism with its
report on the corrosive effects of
social media now much of their report
focused on the ways that social media
supposedly breeds anger and Division
which is not my concern personally you
know I don't think that the internet
causes or breeds anger and division so
much as it gives a forum for these
things to be made manifest in my view
that's one of social media's positive
attributes of anything people who are
angry about the direction of our country
and our culture are are you know going
to be able to voice their concerns
organize mobilize through the internet
and that's a good thing as for the
division our national divide is rooted
in the diametrically opposed worldviews
that broadly separates the two ends of
the political Spectrum it's a spectrum
that hardly even is a spectrum anymore
as a vast Chasm Cuts right down the
middle of it and this divide is
incredibly apparent on social media but
I don't think social media invented it
so the part of the 60 Minutes report
that I found important and worthwhile
was rather the section which focused on
tick tock
and its effect on children specifically
let's watch that
it's owned by a Chinese company called
bite dance and Harris says the version
that served to Chinese consumers called
durian
is very different from the one available
in the West in their version of tick
tock if you're under 14 years old
they show you science experiments you
can do at home Museum exhibits
patriotism videos and educational videos
and they also limit it to only 40
minutes per day now they don't ship that
version of tick tock to the rest of the
world so it's almost like they recognize
that technology is influencing kids
development and they make their domestic
version a spinach version of tick tock
while they've shipped the Opium version
to the rest of the world the version
served to the West has kids hooked for
hours at a time the impact Harris says
is predictable there's a survey of
pre-teens in the U.S and China asking
what is the most aspirational career
that you want to have and the US the
number one was influencer social media
influencer and in China the number one
was astronaut again you allow those two
societies to play out for a few
Generations I can tell you what your
world is going to look like Tick Tock
tells us it gives American users tools
to limit screen time but those tools are
entirely voluntary
so nothing to see here except that Tick
Tock is a communist psyop aimed at
making our children shallow and stupid
and not just shallow and stupid because
the other incredibly significant effect
of social media not just Tick Tock of
course
on our kids is that it is yet one more
Force separating them from us as the
parents this is the aspect not discussed
nearly enough and which is rarely
mentioned in news reports lamenting
rampant social media addiction among
kids
they often leave this part out you know
the average kid spends nine hours a day
consuming media of various kinds usually
through their phone
and if you're anything like the
statistically average parent then you
have really no clue about the nature of
the images sounds and ideas that he
ingests during that span
and naturally we take this all for
granted we assume that this Dynamic is
is natural and normal and basically
healthy
our children exist in their own worlds
their own culture their own language
their own value system their own
celebrities
they become disciples in the Cults of
various idiots on YouTube or Tick Tock
or wherever all of these figures obscure
to us and we imagine that this is just
how it inevitably must be
there's no other feasible option we
think
and we're wrong
because while it's true that older
Generations have always worried about
the younger and the younger Generations
have always exhibited characteristics
that older Generations find puzzling and
troubling
it's not true that young people have
always existed as they do now in their
own universes their own societies with
their own leaders and icons and Prophets
their own religions their own Customs
all of it designed to be indecipherable
and inaccessible to the older
Generations
in fact in the bad old days kids were if
you can imagine it
raised by their parents almost
exclusively not by the internet or TV or
even Public School
kids didn't have a whole life separate
apart from their mothers and fathers
they may have had friends a few not 40
not four thousand
but uh it was their parents who exerted
the most influence over the making and
shaping and forming them as parents are
supposed to do and things started to
change with modern schooling which sent
kids out of the home for most of their
young lives and you know into the care
of strangers
and then a divide became between
Generations became even more vast with
pop culture as kids began to develop
tastes that differed so dramatically
from their parents yet even then
it wasn't like it is now
because yeah kids in the 50s and 60s
they worshiped uh you know Elvis as a
God and they their parents thought that
Elvis was ancient agent of Satan but
their parents at least knew who Elvis
was Elvis was accessible equally to both
parent and child you saw him on TV you
saw you heard him on the radio you know
you bought his music at the store and
and that was about it that's how you
encountered him and then the internet
and now kids have their own version of
Elvis they have like in fact a lot of
Elvis's a lot of little Elvises that
they follow in worship and imitate just
as kids of the 50s and 60s did
but they encounter these new icons in
the void of cyberspace mostly on their
phones out of sight
and there isn't just one Elvis but 400
and they pop up and fade away and change
on a dime the trends move at the speed
of light and the only way to follow
along is to be totally immersed in it
and surrendered to it
so our kids are are pulled along
by these forces they're shaped and
molded by forces that we don't see or
understand and we as parents are
rendered irrelevant
because of the child's phone
in fact if your child is on his phone
nine hours a day it's the phone
and the people that he interacts with
and watches when he uses it that will
form him it's the phone that parents him
your second fiddle at best
and he's not going to hear the tune
you're playing because uh he's on his
phone anyway
so this is not normal it's not healthy
it's not natural
it's not how it's always been
there's really nothing quite analogous
to this in the history of human society
like the the idea of one
Gadget one sort of Little Portal that
kids carry around in their in their
pockets
taking over their lives to this extent
there is no analogy in history
our kids are being destroyed by these
gadgets that we spend exorbitant amounts
of money to provide to them
and I think we have no idea how bad it's
going to get
as our lives migrate more and more into
our phones and our children are resigned
to an existent that existence that can
barely be called human at this point
so
what do we do about it well I think
there are two possible paths forward
there's the path that most parents today
seem to take
which is that you just sort of go with
it
your hand you hand your child the phone
with internet access when he's nine or
ten or whatever you know whenever most
of his friends get one and you give him
one two because I don't want him to feel
left out and you just trust it'll work
out okay
sure he's like 100 guaranteed to develop
a porn habit sure he'll spend all day
absorbing messages and ideas that are
anathema to his intellectual and
spiritual and emotional development sure
his entire life will now revolve around
this damned thing sure all of that is
true but what's the other option to
deprive him of this technology that
everyone else uses
that would make him look uncool
worse it would make the parent look
uncool
people might think that you're you're
poor and you can't afford one
and the trends how can your family keep
up with the trends without the phone
you can't be on trendy you can't let
your kids be on trendy dear God anything
but untrendiness
so that's one path
and if you take that path and you know
then Tick Tock is going to remain a
problem in your life and your family for
your kids
but then number two the other option is
the path Less Traveled
the path that some people would consider
extreme
keep your kid away
from the internet as much as humanly
possible
don't let them have the internet on his
phone
don't let them access the internet in
his room
give them access to one computer
strictly controlled in a visible area of
the house
which he can use with your permission
for a limited amount of time with the
knowledge that you the parent will
review his internet history after he's
finished and go back and watch any
videos he watched and click on the links
he clicked and and read every message he
received
give him no privacy on the internet at
all none
don't trust your child with the internet
that's the worst thing you could do
treat the internet like a very powerful
and potentially dangerous tool which it
is
and treat him like a child who can't be
allowed to use it unsupervised which he
is
so that's the other option
and the great thing is that 60 minutes
talking about Tick Tock and all these
different things
if you take that option then you don't
need to worry about Tick Tock nearly as
much
and so I think that option is probably
the best
and I say that as somebody who makes a
living on the internet
so with all that said what is canceled
today
well I guess parents who give their kids
phones are once again
we must say canceled
so that'll do it for this portion of the
show I hope you get out and uh vote but
before you do we'll get over to our
member block of the program and I hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]